Here’s something that everyone at the SCP
Foundation knows: Portals to another world
located in Indiana are incredibly bad news.
The best example being SCP-2935, the limestone
cavern in Indiana that leads to a dimension
where all life has ended and Death reigns
supreme.
So, considering the importance of keeping
things like this under control, we’ve decided
to fire up the Anom-O-Tron 6000 and simulate
sending one of the Foundation’s most reliable
senior researchers - Dr. Charles Ogden Gears
- to investigate another dimensional anomaly,
this time in a little town called Hawkins,
Indiana.
Can Dr. Gears in his younger years hold his
own against the Demogorgon, Demodogs, the
Mindflayer, and even Vecna himself?
Let’s fire up the machine and find out!
It was November of 1983, and Dr. Gears awoke
to a call on his home phone.
Ordinarily, he liked to start his day with
a cold shower and a cup of plain black coffee,
but on this particular very early morning,
he was yanked out of a lovely, dreamless sleep
by the sound of his superior at the SCP Foundation.
"Gears.
There's something strange going on in this
town in Indiana.
We're putting together a task force, and you're
going to lead it."
"What's been going on?"
"We don't know much yet, but there have been
reports of strange noises, unusual activity,
and a local kid's gone missing.
That was all Dr. Gears needed to hear.
"Alright, I'll start packing."
He placed the phone back in the receiver,
brewed himself that cup of coffee, hopped
in the shower, and filled a suitcase with
all of his usual necessities: flannel pajamas,
five white lab coats, plain slacks, and shirts,
and one pair of sensible shoes.
He dressed in an identical outfit to the ones
lining the inside of his slate grey suitcase,
combed his hair, and straightened his tie,
and that was that.
He was ready for whatever awaited him on this
new mission.
When the official SCP Foundation-issued transportation
came to pick him up, one of the task force
members handed him a dossier, and a thermos
filled with more coffee, enough to sustain
him for the drive.
"So," Dr. Gears flipped open the file, taking
a look inside.
"Where are we headed?"
"Don't know too much about it, sir."
The man shrugged.
"Some little podunk place called Hawkins."
Dr. Gears spent the drive to Hawkins, Indiana,
looking over the few details the Foundation
knew so far.
Their interest had been piqued when a young
boy, Will Byers, disappeared mysteriously
on a bike ride home from a friend's house.
In addition to the missing persons report,
townspeople had called the authorities to
complain about strange noises, and there were
rumors of a secret research project being
conducted by the U.S. Government in the area.
All of these factors combined to make Hawkins
a potential hotbed for anomalous activity,
and a place of significant interest to the
SCP Foundation.
Dr. Gears would be tasked with setting up
a temporary Foundation site in town, disguised
as the headquarters of a new landscaping business,
and leading a group of researchers in the
investigation of the Byers disappearance,
as well as cataloging other potential anomalies
present in the town.
They were to remain there indefinitely, and,
to ensure their work would not be compromised,
they were given strict instructions not to
draw any unnecessary attention to themselves,
from civilians or operatives from any Government
organizations with an established presence
in the town.
As Dr. Gears and his team rolled into the
town, he was struck by how completely, absolutely
ordinary it was.
They passed the town hall, the library, a
general store, a movie theatre, one sleepy
little pub packed with a few regulars, a hunting
and camping supply store, a few diversions
for the kids and young at heart like the arcade,
schools, all hallmarks of classic American
small-town normalcy.
As they drove out into the forest around the
town, however, away from the friendly veneer
of suburbia, Dr. Gears spotted something unusual,
something he made a note of the second he
caught a glimpse of it.There was a large,
official-looking building, surrounded by barbed
wire and armed military guards.
"What's that there?"
He asked one of his assistants.
"Hawkins National Laboratory," she replied.
"Says here they're under the jurisdiction
of the Department of Energy."
"Hm," was all he said.
He would make sure to send someone out to
investigate once they were all settled properly.
After several years at the Foundation, he
had something of a sixth sense for detecting
things that didn't belong.
This place...wasn't what it claimed to be.
By nightfall, Dr. Gears and his team of six
officers had settled into their Foundation-provided
housing, located across the street from their
front business.
Privately, Dr. Gears hoped that the people
of Hawkins weren't especially interested in
landscaping.
He didn't know a damn thing about hedges or
whatever else that job entailed.
While the SCP Foundation maintained a steady,
quiet presence in Hawkins, the anomalous activity
only escalated.
There were reports of a monster, a giant horrible
thing with a humanoid build and a face like
an open flower filled with teeth.
Dr. Gears and four members of the team attempted
to track down one of these creatures, hoping
to bring it into custody and study it up close,
and, outside of the home of the missing boy,
they finally came face to face with the thing.
The predatory creature was tall and thin,
with elongated limbs, ending in sharp claws.
It reminded Dr. Gears a bit of an anomaly
he had seen in passing, though he had never
seen that thing's face.
This beast, however, gave him an up close
and personal look.
At first glance, its head looked like the
closed bud of a flower, with no discernible
features.
However, as it prepared to attack, letting
out an unearthly screech, fleshy petals unfurled,
revealing rows of razor-sharp teeth and a
gaping maw of a mouth.
The officers opened fire immediately, but
the bullets did little to deter the advancing
creature.
They only seemed to make it angry.
Before they could apprehend the creature,
or, more likely, find themselves pulled into
its wide-open mouth, they were interrupted
by a group of surprisingly enterprising children
luring it away, seemingly to trap it.
Two teenage boys and a girl managed to light
the beast on fire, and send it retreating
back to wherever it came from.
Dr. Gears and his men stayed out of sight,
as one of them remarked, "I guess the children
really are our future."
Meanwhile, the other two officers were following
up on reports of a strange girl appearing
in town as if from nowhere.
It was difficult to separate rumor from reality
amidst talk of secret government mind experiments,
roving gangs of children, and something to
do with Eggo waffles, but they managed to
trace the Person of Interest to the local
middle school.
They arrived at the Middle School just in
time to watch the girl use apparent psychic
abilities to fend off government operatives,
before the same monster arrived to massacre
the men as the two operatives watched from
a distance, hidden just out of sight.
They prepared to apprehend the monster and
administer amnestics to the children present,
but before they could, the girl and the monster
were gone.
Shortly after this incident, Will Byers was
reportedly returned to his home.
But Dr. Gears couldn't leave Hawkins just
yet, not with so many new questions unanswered.
Where had the Byers boy been all this time?
What was the creature they had encountered?
Where had it come from?
What had that unusually powerful girl done
with it?
And, most importantly, would more follow in
the beast's footsteps, coming to snatch more
children from the streets?
With authorization from the SCP Foundation,
Dr. Gears reached out to Dr. Owens at the
mysterious laboratory.
He offered to share the information they had
managed to gather, if Dr. Owens would provide
him with full transparency and do the same.
Owens was hesitant, but after being subjected
to one of Dr. Gears' trademark hour-long lectures
consisting of reasoned, logical, extremely
dry arguments, he relented.
Dr. Gears celebrated this little triumph,
and Dr. Owens reported a persistent headache
after listening to the other man prattle on
for such a long time.
Dr. Gears and his team now had concrete information
to share with their higher-ups at the Foundation.
They learned all about the gateway to another
world that the scientists had opened at the
lab, the creatures that had come through its
supernatural doorway, and the connection to
the psychic girl that had disappeared at the
Middle School.
Now that an open line of communication had
been established, Dr. Gears was working to
convince Owens and the rest of the scientists
at the lab to allow him to use their portal.
It was his intention to take his team of six
operatives through the gateway, into this
other world.
There, he would be able to create a first-hand
report for the Foundation, allowing them to
categorize the various creatures inside, and
perhaps the strange new dimension itself.
However, just after Dr. Owens and his staff
agreed to allow an SCP Foundation expedition
into the Upside Down, as it was colloquially
called, disaster struck.
A presence from the other side of the gate
used the Byers boy to infiltrate the laboratory,
dispatching a group of juvenile creatures
to attack the scientists there.
Dr. Gears was inside when it happened, looking
through some of the official reports he had
been granted access to.
Suddenly, there were sounds of chaos from
down the hall, shrieks of terror and agony.
He peered through the window of the room to
see quadrupedal, almost canine variations
on the larger monster bounding down the hallway,
leaving a trail of blood in their wake.
Remembering his commitment to avoid involving
himself unless absolutely necessary, Dr. Gears
barricaded the door and hid from the creatures
as they ripped through the rest of the lab.
The doglike monsters tore the lab staff apart
and injured Dr. Owens in the process.
Then, in retaliation, the psychic girl closed
the gate between the worlds.
In doing so, she removed the threat of the
monsters tearing Dr. Gears limb from limb
as they had so many others, but the damage
was done just the same.
If that wasn't bad enough, a tape of Dr. Owens
speaking candidly about the lab's activity
was leaked to the local media, and the laboratory
was promptly shut down for good.
With it, it seemed all of the Foundation's
access to the anomalies in Hawkins were lost.
Still, in spite of these new obstacles, Dr.
Gears refused to give up.
There were terribly strange things afoot in
Hawkins, and he had been sent there to uncover
them.
He was going to continue to do his job until
some authority told him otherwise.
Besides, he had gotten quite used to living
undercover in this little town.
He didn't get out much, but he hadn't gotten
out all that much before Hawkins either.
It was nice to settle into small-town life,
where very little ever changed...until the
Starcourt Mall opened.
Local businesses began to close, disrupting
Dr. Gears' routine and causing him a great
deal of irritation.
And then, of course, there was the matter
of the secret Russian laboratory beneath that
mall, which unleashed a malevolent entity
from the Upside Down into the town.
The Foundation team watched as, yet again,
the familiar group of civilians neutralized
the threat and closed the gateway to the other
world.
Several of Dr. Gears' assistants suggested
interrogating the civilians, or at the very
least giving them amnestics to make them forget
what they had seen.
Dr. Gears, ever the stickler for the rules,
reminded them that they had been given strict
orders not to interfere.
If the threat moved outside of the bounds
of Hawkins, that would be one thing.
For now, it seemed fairly well-contained.
In fact, it seemed as if it all might be over
for good.
The Byers family left town for California,
and life in town settled back into a mundane
rhythm.
Or, at least it did, until the murders began.
First, a well-liked cheerleader, found mutilated
in a trailer.
Then, an ambitious student reporter.
The town flew into chaos, blaming anything
they could think of for the horrific losses.
Dungeons and Dragons, the misunderstood tabletop
roleplaying game, was a convenient scapegoat.
But of course, Dr. Gears knew better.
This was the influence of something from the
other side, something not of this plane.
If only he could get back through a gate,
and finally take a look for himself.
Dr. Gears was not a praying kind of man, but
his quiet wishes were answered when one of
his men returned to headquarters after taking
a swim in a nearby lake.
He ran through the door, still sopping wet.
"Sir!"
He panted, "You're gonna want to see this."
"Please get a towel first."
Dr. Gears insisted.
"You're dripping all over the floor.
It's hardwood; show some decency."
After the man was sufficiently dry, Dr. Gears
brought the team to investigate the lake.
There, at the bottom of the water, was an
ominous red glow.
A gate.
He couldn't be sure how, or why, it had opened
on its own down there, but an opportunity
had finally presented itself.
He called his superiors at the Foundation,
suited up in protective gear complete with
pistols and waterproof communication systems,
and dove down into the water, three officers
right behind him.
The other three would remain on the other
side, ready to call for backup, or swiftly
flee town, if anything went sideways.
Finally, Dr. Gears would lead an expedition
into the Upside Down.
As they swam toward the bottom of the lake,
into the gate to the unknown, writhing black
tendrils slithered out from the opening, snaking
around the three men accompanying him, and
yanking them through.
Dr. Gears was an excellent swimmer, the monotony
of laps in his local pool being one of his
favorite ways to maintain top-notch physical
shape, and he sped through the water after
them.
When he entered the gate, he suddenly emerged
into a dark facsimile of the world he had
just left behind.
He peered through the visor of his suit, taking
in his surroundings.
It was a cold, shadowy landscape, shaped vaguely
like Hawkins, but alien and foreboding.
More of those vine-like tentacles curled along
the ground, and gray spores drifted through
the air like falling snow.
The cries of strange creatures filled the
air, drowned out only by...
The pained screams of the three men he had
followed through the gate!
Dr. Gears looked around for the source of
the sound, and spotted it: the three members
of personnel were struggling to free themselves
from the grip of the ropy tendrils that had
pulled them inside, and as they did, winged
creatures were descending on them from above,
on all sides.
They vaguely resembled bats, with flapping
leathery wings, but their faces, their mouths,
were completely unlike anything Dr. Gears
had ever seen, with the exception of the other
monsters that had crossed through the rift
from this place and into his own world.
These bat-like creatures were swarming his
team, biting at their flesh as the men helplessly
tried to fend them off.
There was only one thing to do: Dr. Gears
drew his weapon and fired it into the sky
at the teeming mass of wings and teeth.
The bat-things reacted and turned their attention
to him.
His marksmanship did not miss, however, and
he managed to take out a dozen or so of the
vermin before his men could free themselves
and come to his aid.
Two of his men, at least.
One, unfortunately, succumbed to his wounds,
and would have to be left behind.
It was a shame, of course, but he knew what
he was signing up for when he joined the ranks
of the Foundation.
It was then that Dr. Gears remembered something
else he had brought with him, inspired by
the victory he had witnessed all that time
ago.
The only thing that had sent the monster back
to hell was fire, so he had strapped a Foundation-issued
flamethrower to his back.
He drew this secondary weapon, a flamethrower,
and sent a blast of flame soaring through
the air, barbecuing the bats to a crisp.
With the threat dispelled, at least temporarily,
he beckoned the men to follow him through
the unforgiving landscape, making note of
everything that he saw.
For each and every detail that made Hawkins
memorable, there was an equivalent to it here,
covered in those strange spores and a layer
of palpable malice.
As the group made their way through the Upside
Down, Dr. Gears at the front, they spotted
what appeared to be the remains of the teenagers
whose deaths were being investigated in town.
They were bound up in the vines, left on display...but
by what?
Or, more likely, by who?
Dr. Gears could not see any other sign of
human life here.
As his mind began to wander, running through
the possibilities, something caught his attention.
A long, loud, clear sound, like the ringing
of church bells.
No, not quite.
Like the chime of a grandfather clock.
It rang once.
Twice.
Three times.
A fourth.
He couldn't see a clock anywhere, but the
sound appeared to be coming from a massive
house up ahead.
Nestled within the trees, the eerie red light
just barely illuminated the place's silhouette.
But as Gears and his remaining two assistants
approached, he could see that it was a stately
home, now in obvious disrepair.
He had somehow missed its earthbound equivalent
and had never seen the place before.
But here it was, the door standing open, as
if beckoning him inside.
"Wait here, keep watch."
He nodded to the officers behind him.
"I'll take it from here."
With his pistol in one hand, and the other
poised and ready to draw the flamethrower
at a moment's notice, he stepped into the
house.
He was right to have his weapon drawn.
No sooner had he stepped inside than the vines
coiled around his ankles, one winding around
his throat and squeezing.
With a few quick shots, he was able to force
them to recede, and continued his investigation.
He climbed the creaky stairs to the attic,
looking for signs of new life.
He briefly thought of trying to use his communicator
to check in with the men on the other side,
but when he pressed its buttons, it only emitted
white noise.
It was a favorite sound of his, one he vastly
preferred to the cacophony of music, but now
was not the time.
He switched it back off, and carried on alone.
Then, just as he crossed the threshold into
the attic, he heard it again.
The chime of the clock.
In the corner of his eye, he spotted it, an
antique grandfather clock.
Before he could react to that, though, he
heard a voice behind him.
"Daddy?"
He turned to see a little girl staring up
at him.
"Why are you leaving us?
Don't you love us?"
He was too stunned to speak.
The little girl's eyes turned white, her face
dripping like melting wax, as she repeated,
"Why did you leave?
Why?
Why?"
He couldn't explain it, but his heart began
to pound, he could taste blood in the back
of his throat.
Behind the little girl, a figure emerged,
human in shape only, a twisted face and form
made of exposed muscle and more of those awful
tentacle vines approaching him slowly.
"It haunts you, doesn't it, doctor?
What you did to your family?"
the figure asked in a menacing voice.
Finally, Dr. Gears found the ability to speak
again.
"This all seems like a bit much.
Don't you think?"
He didn't have much patience for pageantry
of any kind, and he certainly didn't appreciate
this.
"What is this...some sort of psionic mind
prison?"
The entity that Dr. Gears had no name for,
but those determined kids from Hawkins knew
as Vecna, tilted its head to the side quizzically.
"I can see your heart.
I know the darkness within you," It hissed.
Dr. Gears reached down for his communicator,
giving it one more shot as the entity approached
him with slow, threatening steps.
As it reached its fingers toward his face,
he flipped a switch, and that lovely white
noise blared to life.
Suddenly, the vision of the little girl was
gone.
The clock stopped chiming.
Vecna was still there, though, glowering at
Dr. Gears with a mixture of fury and just
plain irritation.
"I have more important things to attend to
than you.
Go back to your world...while you still can."
With a flick of his wrist, Vecna threw Dr.
Gears back down the stairs and out the front
door of the house, where his assistants were
still dutifully waiting.
Dr. Gears was preparing to inform them of
his discovery, when he heard several new voices
in the distance, human and familiar.
Those same children were back, once again,
seemingly to save the day as they had so many
times before.
Ever the pragmatist, Dr. Gears brushed himself
off and headed back in the direction he came.
Best to stay out of their way.
Shortly after, Dr. Gears and his task force
withdrew from Hawkins, Indiana, returning
to their original Foundation Sites.
They could monitor the situation from afar,
and in the meantime, leave Hawkins to the
US Government, the Russians, and that constantly
surprising group of brave, clever civilians.
Hell, maybe a few of them could be recruited
to join the Foundation when they got a bit
older.
When asked to submit an official report on
his findings in Hawkins, and his recommendation
for how the Foundation should proceed with
the situation there, Dr. Gears simply wrote
this: "To be completely honest, I think those
kids have got it covered."
Now go check out “SCP-096 VS Siren Head”
and “Could SCP-682 be Contained in the Backrooms?”
for more anomalous crossovers that are out
of this world!